RICHARD: Hi.
Good afternoon, and welcome to
our interview with the GPDC
team, also known as the
Google Play Developer
Console Preview team.
Today we're joined in our lovely
Hangout little room
here with Ricardo and
Max and Ellie and--
PIERRE: Pierre.
RICHARD: Pierre.
Slightly awkward moment as I
don't know Pierre's name.
And of course we're here to
discuss the brand new Google
Play Developer Console Preview,
which hopefully
you've had a good chance to try
out, see the new features
through the awesome new UI.
I'll leave you in the capable
hands of Max, I think, to
start with.
He's going to run through
some demos for us
of all the new features.
ELLIE: So really quickly before
we jump into demos, I
guess wanted to just make sure
you all know why we built a
new developer console.
Big reasons we've gotten from it
was, you guys are using the
developer console more and
more to update your
applications.
You're really growing
your businesses.
And we had a bunch of features
we want to be able to add in
the future.
And we wanted to give you
a great user experience.
So that was the motivation
for doing it.
And so this year at Google I/O
we announced and demoed the
new developer console.
And then last week, you all got
access, as Richard mentioned.
So we wanted to say that what
we have here is a preview.
It's not totally done yet.
I'm sure many of you have found
things that you'd like
to see improved before
we consider it done.
And there are a couple
of features we
haven't released yet.
But we also hope that you'll
see this as kind of a
foundation and a platform
for more things to come.
So we really welcome all of your
feedback about how we can
continue to improve it.
So Max is going to walk us
through what we have in the
preview today.
MAX: Cool.
Richard, can we make my screen
visible for everyone?
RICHARD: Of course we can.
MAX: Perfect.
Here we go.
You may remember the demo at
the Google I/O. So you may
remember this app.
So basically that's the
Start page if you
arrive on the new page.
And you see the handy Developer
Guide, which got
published during the
demo at Google I/O.
So you start with the store
listing with the most
important information
about your app.
What's interesting is with the
new page, we now support up to
49 localized information.
So for instance, let's try to
add some German to that app.
We still call it the handy
Developer Guide.
And you can add description
and so on and so forth.
We can save and publish
Drive guests.
We should get an
error for that.
You see, we also tried to give
you way better information.
If you do something wrong, what
you did wrong, what you
should do to fix that.
But let's see.
Let's fix it.
ELLIE: It's not a very
interesting app, is it?
So one of the other things that
you'll notice, like Max
mentioned, is you have up to 49
languages, which is a lot
more than we had before.
We have some languages like UK
English and Turkish that we
didn't have before.
And another thing that you'll
also notice, it's kind of an
invisible feature.
For listings where you don't
provide a manual translation
or a human translation, we'll
create an automated
translation using Google
Translate behind the scenes.
And then users who are
encountering your store
listing, if it's not in their
native language, once you've
saved it to the new developer
console, they'll actually see
a button allowing them to view
an automated translation.
So just to be clear, the
automated translations are
generated by Google Translate.
And so they're obviously not
going to be as good as having
a native speaker of German,
like Max, creating the
translation.
But until such time as you're
able to get the servicers of a
professional translator, they
certainly will go a long way.
And you don't have to do
anything to make the automated
translations happen.
Once you've saved your app to
the new developer console,
they'll happen behind
the scenes.
And you can go ahead and update
the default language as
often as you want, and the
automated translations will
update automatically.
This is a change from the old
developer console, wherein you
used to have to select an
automated translation for each
language where you wanted one.
And then they didn't
update properly.
So here it all happens behind
the scenes as soon as you've
saved your app in
the new console.
MAX: We've seen, usually,
German is too long.
So we leave it here in
the original title.
OK.
We've saved these changes.
Let's have a look
into the other--
I have to click that
obviously.
RICHARD: And you get the
little running Android.
MAX: Yeah, the running Android
is one of the best parts of
the new app.
ELLIE: I think that was the most
popular feature with our
Developer Relations team.
They really liked the
running Android.
MAX: We love it.
Some kind of progress is
always nice, right?
ELLIE: Yeah, exactly.
And it's just cute.
I think it's cute.
MAX: So yeah, the list of
countries where you can
publish your app.
Obviously if you have a paid
app, you see and can set the
prices here.
This app has no inner
products.
Let's look into the
APK screen.
Again, we tried to give you as
much information as we can
give you on that page.
And see like the supported
devices, I think this is a
great way to go through Earth
through the devices to see
where your app is working
or where not.
Or even If you even want to
exclude devices because
there's certain handsets where
you have problems.
You can add that here as well.
And obviously if you have
an update, you can
upload new APK here.
And you see the changes.
So for instance, we have now
localized information for
German in the app.
I think it's pretty good here
because you may unfortunately
use the wrong APK to upload
or something like that.
And you get immediately the
information of what changed.
So we want to just give you as
much information as we can
give you to prevent any mistakes
from your side.
Let's have a look
into statistics.
Same statistics.
We will see some more on
a different tab soon.
We have all of these different
dimensions.
If you're ever in doubt what it
exactly means, there's the
handy tool to give you details
about the differences between
active and total devices
and users.
I think once you get used to
it, you know what it means.
And it's just, again, great.
We want to give you, just
repeat myself, as much
information.
And we will let the decision for
you to what you actually
want and how you
want to use it.
The new crashes overview
is also pretty cool.
So we have a bunch of filters.
And you can go through
the stack traces.
And you also might have that
visible on the last report
here on that part, if you can
see the mouse pointer.
We also jump through the
details of everything.
ELLIE: Yes, this is when I
forgot that grid layout didn't
exist in older versions.
That was a good lesson for me.
MAX: Happens.
And as well, the
user messages.
Hopefully they will give useful
information, like how
it exactly happened.
Let's jump into one of Rich's
apps, where we have pretty
cool ratings.
Because it's an awesome
app, obviously.
RICHARD: Ultimate Stopwatch.
MAX: It's a new dimension
just recently added.
Ricardo, maybe you can say
a bit more about that.
RICARDO: Yeah, we use it to
display basically how your
ratings have evolved
over time.
Because often that's an
interesting method to keep
track of, to measure
user satisfaction.
And we offer you basically
two new metrics.
One is the cumulative
average rating.
And it tells you basically the
average of all the ratings
that your application has
gathered over time.
And this is exactly what you see
also in the storefront on
play.google.com of the actual
rating that the
user has given you.
And so basically, the last point
in the chart that says
that we have a rating of 4.35
should match what you see on
the storefront above the
rating that your
app currently has.
The extra information that you
get here, in addition to the
history over the time of this
rating, is the breakdown by
all the usual dimensions that
you're already used to from
the other metrics
that we offer.
So for example, you could see
by, I don't know, how the
rating is divided by device.
And you can see maybe that some
users from given devices
give you a lower rating
than other users.
And maybe this is indicative
that you have not optimized
your application for
a given device.
Maybe it uses a different screen
size, and you have not
really optimized for that.
So the user experience
is less optimal.
By language as well, maybe you
have not optimized your
application for a
given language.
You have not localized.
So your user rated poorly.
And another interesting one
is by application version.
Because you can see by rolling
out new version whether people
like it more or not.
And maybe your new version is
not as good as you thought,
and you want to do some fixes
and change it again.
If the cumulative average rating
over time provides a
too broad metric, because it
accumulates all the rating
even from last versions, even
from previous, if you have
been out for a long time,
previous months, previous
years, then you can switch to
the daily average rating,
which is exactly the same metric
but aggregated over a
daily basis.
And this gives you a much more
granular information about how
on each day uses are rating
your application.
And again, depending on how many
users you have, you may
have various [? interactive ?]
information that shows you on
a particular day what is the
average rating that your
application got.
And this gives you much more
detailed information.
For example, when you want to
closely track how a new launch
is happening, how a new
launch is going.
And as usual, you can always
export this metric, just like
all the others.
So if you want to do your own
custom aggregations on your
site by merging together other
data sources, you can get a
full breakdown in CSP
format as well.
So you can proceed from there.
RICHARD: That's absolutely
excellent.
I didn't know the
ratings trending
existed inside the reporting.
Has that been in the stats since
the new stats were in?
ELLIE: No, this is actually a
launch last Monday with the
new developer console preview.
RICHARD: Well, I'm sure
to make use of that.
I'm working on an update to the
Ultimate Stopwatch anyway.
It's likely we'll be able to
see the trending app as--
ELLIE: I was noticing on your
stats, actually, that for your
latest version, that had an
actually better user rating
than the other versions.
I'm not sure if you knew
that, but your update
really was an update.
It was a good update.
MAX: And I know you're working
on tablet support.
So you can see which devices are
rating it higher, if the
tablets are now liking
it more.
ELLIE: That's true, you can see
if the Nexus 7 users are
enjoying that one.
MAX: That's brilliant.
RICARDO: And on this case,
you maybe should work on
localization for Portuguese.
ELLIE: You're not very happy.
RICHARD: Can you just
do that for me now?
Just press the--
MAX: I don't know.
I can help you with German.
RICHARD: No, the automatic
translation--
MAX: Oh, yeah, that's right.
ELLIE: The automatic
translations are just for the
store listing.
That's not actually for
the applications.
Or maybe Portuguese users are
just more unhappy than the
Dutch users, I'm not sure.
MAX: Talking writing in reviews,
actually, forgot to
show that page as well,
to give you an
overview about the ratings.
But as we just encountered, the
greater overview and the
details are on the
statistics page.
And our products are also part
of the developer console.
Some of you had early access,
but that's now as well live.
So if you want to add
a new product--
there's a typo.
Want to fix that, because you
can't do it otherwise
afterwards.
Manage product.
And again, it looks pretty
similar to the store listing
page for your main app.
We didn't want to confuse you
with too many different
widgets and so on.
You can add all of your
information here, as you're
used to from your store listing,
obviously just what
is required for inner
products.
And easy, just do the
auto convert.
You may want to check the
detailed prices, because
guessing euro maybe 2.49
sounds a bit better.
But again, want to give you
the tools so you can do
everything easily.
It's sometimes a
bit difficult.
But we always try.
We know some of you developers
have full time jobs.
And you love to develop
for Android and
do that on the side.
And we try to support you in the
same way as we do it for
big developers.
But as we said, we are happy
to get some feedback today
from all backgrounds
of developers.
So let us know if you have
any wishes or ideas.
And we're more than happy to
discuss that, and maybe even
do it in the end.
We have also the service in
APIs here, if you, for
instance, use Google Talk
messaging, you can
configure that here.
And I think that's
basically format.
I'm not sure Ricardo
has anything else?
RICARDO: That's pretty
much it.
ELLIE: Yeah.
We hope you all give it a try.
And one other thing to point out
if you haven't noticed it
is the gigantic orange link that
say, give us feedback, in
the upper right hand corner.
We read all that feedback
personally.
And although we're not able to
respond to every message that
we get, we do keep it all in
mind when we're planning
future updates.
So please click on it, let us
know what you think, and tell
your friends.
RICHARD: Thank you very much.
Excellent.
Some good stats.
And the fact that I've learned
something is also kind of
handy, too.
Is the trending ratings the
only new statistic?
Is there anything else
I would've missed?
ELLIE: No, those are the new
ones that we launched with the
open preview.
So we definitely see that as
a great way to identify
opportunities to improve your
app, and to also see, every
time you release a new version,
did it actually
improve what your users
think about you.
RICHARD: Hopefully it does.
ELLIE: That's always the goal.
MAX: Leave it on, maybe we want
to switch back, but I
think we can.
RICHARD: OK.
Hello, everybody.
So we have some questions
in the moderator.
But if you're thinking of
joining the Hangout and asking
the GPDC team something live,
now's a good time to jump in.
And we'll get you lined up
to ask the questions.
Also, you can comment on
the G+ post for this.
And we'll be reading
those as well.
So do you have something
from the moderator?
NICK: Yeah, I can dive in to
the moderator questions.
Before we go into the questions,
I think it's best
to reiterate, as we always say
on our developer Hangouts,
that we're not going to
be making any product
announcements here.
We're going to be discussing
your comments and feedback.
But any questions of, when will
X launch, when will I get
feature Y, that we're not
going to be able to talk
about, I'm afraid.
So I think the best way to
direct the conversation is to
give us constructive feedback of
what you like, and what you
would like to see more
of from the team.
But asking for launch
dates, not so much.
So with that in mind, when
will it be possible to
moderate comments on
applications, is I guess one
of these forward-looking
statements we're not going to
really get into, like we said.
ELLIE: Well, I guess what we
can say so far is that we
realize that this was a really
important feature for
developers.
So we wanted to get it out there
as soon as possible.
We've definitely heard very
strong feedback from a lot of
developers who don't have access
yet that they do want
to have access.
So we hear that you want
to have the access.
But we're still trying to make
sure that the feature's
working exactly as it should
for developers and users.
And hopefully, we'll
be able to roll it
out more in the future.
But as Nick mentioned, we
can't really make any
announcements in this meeting.
NICK: So the next question
is again asking
for when will X happen.
But I'm going to rephrase
it into feedback.
Cicero in France asks, he says
that his screen shots and
feature promo graphics at the
moment come out slightly
blurry due to compression.
And so I'm going to rephrase
that to, are we aware of this?
And are we looking into this?
RICARDO: Yes, we are.
So we're aware that in the
process in some cases, the
screen shot maybe got resized
in a way that--
NICK: So we compress it on
our end to save space.
RICARDO: Yeah.
We do some optimizations
for serving as well.
And so yes, we're
aware of that.
NICK: OK.
So watch your space,
essentially.
RICHARD: OK.
We've got someone joining
us in the Hangout.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes,
one small thing.
You said that you posted on the
YouTube channel to go to
the link in the description.
There is no link in
the description.
I was trying to put something in
the moderator, but I don't
have a link in the
description.
NICK: Apparently if you
try hitting refresh?
MALE SPEAKER: I have.
And I've closed the page
and reloaded it.
Still nothing.
RICHARD: All right.
Let me take a look.
I'll try to fix that for you.
We've got a [INAUDIBLE]
engineer extraordinaire from the
mountain view office has
kindly dialed in live.
You might've seen his face
appear in the bottom corner.
So hopefully we can get
that sorted out
for you pretty instantly.
NICK: Next question from the
moderator, Oren in Israel
asks, how can I delete or
hide an unpublished app?
ELLIE: Well, that is something
that has gotten nearly as many
requests as being able
to reply to reviews.
I think it's something that
we're looking into.
Nothing to announce
at this point.
But thanks for that feedback.
We've definitely heard from
developers that they want a
way to kind of de-clutter
their interface.
Some people only have one or two
apps and they don't have
this problem.
But some people have
all sorts of apps.
And at some point they decide
that they don't want to
maintain that app anymore.
Or they've created it by
accident, and they'd
like to remove it.
So yeah, thanks for
that feedback.
RICHARD: Am I right in thinking
you can delete an app
if it's never been published?
ELLIE: Not in the new site.
It hasn't been implemented
yet.
Like I said, totally
not finished yet.
This is one of the things we
haven't implemented yet.
RICHARD: So the thing to do
would be to create a second
Android in front of a console
account, and then use the app
transfer to transfer
all your apps.
ELLIE: No!
Just ignore it!
Just ignore it for now.
Sorry it's a bit cluttered.
RICHARD: Yeah.
It'll sort itself out.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK: Next question, so Nikolai
in Tokyo, he's asking,
are there any plans to publish
an API for app statistics?
So I guess we're not going
to comment on future
plans and so on.
But I guess we could fit that
into feedback, that he would
love to see some
statistics API.
So I guess that would be nice
for automating your own
reporting mechanisms.
ELLIE: Yeah, definitely.
In the meantime, you can
use the CSV export.
But thanks for that feedback.
RICHARD: So we have heard that
feedback I think more than
once already.
ELLIE: Many times, yeah.
RICARDO: CSV is obviously not
as powerful as an API.
But it is the easiest form to
get access to those data.
And it's a bit hard to discover,
but CSV also include
more complete breakdown than
the other metrics.
On this interface, you
see only the top 10.
But if you get the CSV, for
example, you get the full list
of devices, if you are looking
at device dimension.
And so you can do more complete
analysis by using that.
NICK: So definitely worth going
into that CSV if you
haven't tried it yet.
And just rely on the
top 10 graphs.
RICARDO: We have heard
the requests about
more complete APIs.
NICK: Cool, awesome.
Next request is obviously, user
X is loving the new dev
console so much he wants the
choice to be sticky rather
than having to opt
in every time.
When he switched to try the new
dev console, he says he
has to check it every time.
RICARDO: Yes, that is correct.
It's not a stick yet.
MAX: Just put in a bookmark
to the new one.
The thing is--
RICHARD: It's a V2.
MAX: It's a different
URL, so--
ELLIE: Bookmark it for now.
RICHARD: Change your bookmarks,
there we go.
Also, Oren, about deleting apps
from your account, I just
had an idea that you could just
rename the apps that you
don't like to zed zed zed.
And they would just go down
to the bottom of the list.
I've just been into my accounts
and renamed the apps
that I didn't want
to see there.
And they've all gone straight
to the bottom of the list.
NICK: Or put a tilde or
something next to it.
RICHARD: So at least you don't
have to look at them anymore,
even if they're just at the
bottom of the page.
ELLIE: That's a good idea.
RICHARD: Does the new console
have a limit to the number of
apps that appear on
the front page?
RICARDO: It's 50 per page.
We did a few estimations of
the average number of
applications.
That seems to be a good
compromise between the
different usages.
And also trying to get
everything in one page.
Before it was eight applications
per page, and it
was just not.
RICHARD: Someone else has joined
us in the Hangout.
It is [? Sonel. ?]
[? Sonel, ?] do you have any
questions for the developer
console team?
MALE SPEAKER: Hello?
NICK: Hello.
You're very quiet.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello?
ELLIE: Hello.
MALE SPEAKER: I have
a question.
RICHARD: Yeah, please,
go ahead.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a question
regarding Android.
Hello?
RICHARD: Hi.
Please go ahead and
ask the question.
MALE SPEAKER: I want to know,
how [INAUDIBLE] secure using
Android apps?
NICK: How secure is it
to use Android apps?
OK, so I don't think that's
really a question for the
Android publisher site.
Can you perhaps come back into
our office hours we have on
Wednesdays at 2:00 PM GMT and
ask the question there?
We're going to focus
on the developer
console for this session.
OK?
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
NICK: Sorry.
RICHARD: Thanks for joining
us though, cheers.
NICK: OK.
Back into the moderator.
So there's a feature request
here that Ashley in London
would like to see us order--
comments on devices by those
comments left by people in the
same device.
So feedback, I guess, for the
Google Play client team.
ELLIE: Sorry, what was it?
Was it being able to--
NICK: They'd like to see
comments, when they're looking
at an application on device in
the Google Play store, to see
comments rated or ranked by
users of the same device.
ELLIE: Yeah.
That's an interesting
feedback.
RICARDO: Isn't that labeled
already in the Google client?
You can see--
NICK: You can see what
device it came from.
RICARDO: From my device?
RICHARD: There is a filter
in there, isn't there?
ELLIE: It's hard to find, but
I think it does exist.
RICHARD: Maybe it
already exists.
NICK: In the web version,
you're saying, or?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICARDO: Reviews from my
device, or something.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ELLIE: You have to click
on Reviews first.
RICHARD: See All Reviews.
Most helpful first, highest
rating, newest, options, for
my device model only.
So whoever asked
that question--
NICK: Ashley in London.
RICHARD: Ashley in London,
there's an option-- not that
you're going to be able to see
this-- it's on the right hand
side of the ratings.
And you can press it
and choose for my
device model only.
Excellent.
NICK: Next question, Andy in
Brooklyn in USA asks, are you
planning an API to facilitate
automated or at least more
streamlined published
and updating?
So I guess you can't say are
we going to do it or are we
going to launch it or whatever,
but is it feedback
that you've heard?
ELLIE: We've definitely
heard it before.
And I think for developers who
have larger numbers of
applications, some of them have
definitely requested this.
NICK: My problem with such
things is that I could see
people using it to publish to
multiple places at once, in
which case you get to the lowest
common denominator
approach, where they're not
taking advantage of things
like the stream translation,
and so on and so forth that
other storefronts
might not offer.
RICARDO: May be helpful,
depending if you have
customized build tools and
workflows, at which point
publishing is just at the
end of your train.
But there is the moderation.
RICHARD: Quite interesting
comment from Daniel Baines on
the G+ post, one that I hadn't
thought about before but may
not be too tricky.
It's about promoting
your applications.
At the moment, we give people
access to the Google Play
branding, in that little button
so they can put it in
their website.
He's asking for an embeddable
widget that he can put in his
website where it will list his
applications on the Play store
in a nice format with the
ratings that they have.
And just let people
click straight
through, and can buy them.
ELLIE: Ooh, thanks
for that idea.
RICHARD: Thank you, Daniel.
NICK: That is cool.
RICHARD: Well, anything
to help promote.
NICK: We could talk about the
badge, because we don't really
have the badge generators for
individual apps at the
moment, don't we?
We don't have one for the
publisher page, as well.
RICHARD: For all your apps.
NICK: Cicero, again, in France
asks, there's currently no way
to prepare a full release.
You can upload an APK.
But all of the extra
information-- descriptions,
screen shot, et cetera-- are
not part of a release.
As a result, APK and information
are currently made
available independently.
That makes sense?
RICARDO: Yeah, that is true.
So at the moment, after you have
published, then you add
it physically each part of the
application independently.
But until the moment you
publish, you're free to modify
and add information as soon
as you gather them.
So you can start by saying,
I'm putting in the store
listing or a screen shot,
because that's what my
designer gave me first.
And one day if APK's
ready, you can add
that in a second moment.
Until the moment of your first
publishing time, you're free
to assemble your application
in bits and pieces.
NICK: So I guess he's asking
for a way to tie that
description and everything to
a particular release rather
than having a--
ELLIE: We've definitely had some
developers ask for that.
Because they want to be able
to do exactly what he's
talking about, prepare
everything and then at one
moment, release it as a unit.
So we've definitely
heard that.
MAX: So basically it would be
up and ready for new apps.
But ones that are published,
then they're unfortunately
losing that possibility of
editing on the fly without
publishing.
But yeah.
RICHARD: I know when you upload
a new application it
can take you a couple of
hours to get through to
people to see it.
If you make content description
changes at the
same time as uploading, do the
description changes go live in
a different time to the APK?
Or does it all happen
at the same time?
ELLIE: It's a good question.
RICARDO: There's a bit of
caching and optimizations
involved in the pipeline through
which from the moment
you submit something to the
moment it gets live.
And that's also something to--
I'm not sure [INAUDIBLE].
But there are different groups,
there are different
bits of information they take
before they go live.
RICHARD: Interesting.
NICK: There's another request
here on the moderator, so
Lukas, is that Lukas Ruecker?
RICHARD: Ah, Lukas has joined
us here as well.
NICK: Ah, do you want to
ask your question live?
RICHARD: Hi Lukas, thanks
for joining us.
LUKAS: I added a question.
But I thought it would be
nicer to ask personally.
So I know there's something in
Google Play for tracking
campaigns and all.
So you can know where your new
installs are coming from.
But that involves changes
in the app and all.
And for indy developers that
don't have a lot of
infrastructure, you need to send
this with some server.
So it's more work when you
don't have time or
resources to do it.
So It would be really nice if
there was some sort of super
simple mechanism to
track where new
installs are coming from.
It could be things, for a start,
like tracking what
search keywords trigger new
installs inside the client.
So either web or on desktop
or the mobile app
on the Android device.
That's one.
Let's see, maybe which page
opened Google Play to install
the new app?
So that's nice for if you have a
landing page, then if you're
triggering the installs from
there, you have some sort of
way to gauge that.
So that's another one.
Anyway, just a few ideas.
But having a simpler version
of tracking referrers on
Google Play would be useful,
especially for people who
don't have a lot of
infrastructure.
ELLIE: And so this would be like
something even simpler
than integrating Google
Analytics?
Is that kind of what
you're looking for?
LUKAS: Yes-ish?
The thing is, so just my
personal take on that, I
usually try to avoid adding
Google Analytics if I don't
have a very strong reason
for doing that.
If I can have just a simple way
to track where people are
finding the app and installing
it, that's fine.
Because Google Analytics takes
bandwidth and a lot of data
connection costs involved
for users.
So if I can avoid that, I
prefer to not add that.
ELLIE: OK.
LUKAS: So it's just maybe a
simple mechanism to track
where the install came from.
And if you want to go further
in adding your own
infrastructure for service
side, or even Google
Analytics, that's
another step.
NICK: Yeah.
It's a good idea.
For those of you who don't know
what Lukas is referring
to, there is a method at the
moment if you're tracking
install referrers.
If you Google for Android and
referrer, you'll find a way
you can pass particular
kind of campaign
IDs all the way through.
So you can track the
effectiveness.
But I agree.
There's some work to
be done there.
And maybe there's a better
way to automatically
service this stuff.
So thanks for the feedback.
So next question is
Daniel in London.
Is that you, Daniel?
Will it be possible in the
future for a developer page to
show developer details?
And perhaps even integrate with
their Google+ account?
So that's a good idea.
Thank you for the feature
suggestion.
And that'll be quick cool.
Because at the moment, if you go
to a developer's page, you
just see the list of
their applications.
So it might be nice to have
some blow up there.
Cool.
Thanks for the request.
RICHARD: We've got another
one in the G+
stream from Philip Madison.
He says he would like to be able
to click on the headers
of the all application section
to reorder the listings.
To go to the app with the most
downloads, with the most
money, pretty much
all those things.
ELLIE: OK.
Thanks for that.
RICHARD: Thanks, Philip.
Any more moderators?
NICK: Yeah, there's a last one
is saying, any plans for
better support for ProGuard?
And to easier read your stack
traces when they'll be
ProGuarded?
ELLIE: Oh, for native crashes?
NICK: Yeah. well no, just
ProGuarded normal files.
If you upload your mapping file
for the APK, so you can
decode the stack traces.
Yeah, native is another
kettle of fish.
But yeah, thanks for
the feedback.
Like we said, we're not going
to comment on whether it's
coming or not.
But thank you for the request.
I think we exhausted
the moderator.
RICHARD: Running low
on questions now.
So we'll wrap it up.
But if [? Adira, ?] who's just
joined us again, has another
question for us, please.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I wrote
it on the moderator.
But you said that one
was the last one.
So I don't know, maybe it
doesn't record mine.
I wanted to ask if there will
be a way to reply for users,
not developers, to reply like
the developers can reply.
I mean when in an app, there are
many apps in Google Play
that the developer has
sort of abandoned.
And many people with
questions there.
You understand what
I'm saying?
So they ask question
and there's no
way to reply to them.
NICK: So you want to,
as a user, reply to
another user's comment?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Because you can see, for
example, ADW Launcher, it
seems like the developer
completely neglects it.
And there are a ton of people
with questions there.
And no one can answer them.
RICARDO: Sort of self-support
forum for users of an app.
ELLIE: Yeah.
Huh, haven't heard that
request before.
It's interesting.
RICHARD: Almost turns into a
comments thread instead of a--
ELLIE: Yeah, more of a forum.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, just like
YouTube, for example.
You have replies, comments.
NICK: Not sure that's an example
you want to emulate.
Thank you for the feedback.
RICHARD: Are you checking the
YouTube comments, Daniel?
Any good questions
coming through?
DANIEL: There are
many questions.
But none of them are related.
RICHARD: And if any of you are
wondering throughout this
Hangout why mine and Nick's
heads are so much bigger than
everyone else's, it's because
they're actually beamed in
from another studio.
And there's a green screen
here and we're just
superimposing.
So it's just been faked
interactions.
Or we've just got big heads.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a question
that's not exactly
related if you don't mind.
It's about the market, the Play,
but not the developers.
In the market, there was a way
to download more than one app.
Since you updated to Play, it
downloads one at a time.
So if you're downloading
like a one
gigabyte, it takes forever.
And the other one don't
download until
the first ones finish.
RICHARD: It's interesting.
Hadn't noticed that
it switched over.
You mean before-- do you know
how many would downloaded at
the time before?
Was it just two at a time?
MALE SPEAKER: No,
indefinitely.
You have, like, 50 updates, I
do update all, and they all
download at once.
RICHARD: And now it's
done serially
instead of in parallel.
MALE SPEAKER: They were doing
it together, simultaneously,
but slower speed.
But in general, overall
it was faster than
just one at a time.
RICHARD: I guess the problem
with that is you end up--
I don't know what the actual
problem was-- but you could
end up with five apps finishing
at the same time,
and then trying to install.
So the installer still
has to stack them
one after the other.
Because you can only be
installing one app at a time.
But I didn't know that
had happened.
MALE SPEAKER: It used to be one
of the up points against
iOS that I used to
use for people.
But now iOS--
NICK: Update all all the time.
RICHARD: And just for it.
MALE SPEAKER: Because now iOS
does have this ability.
And Android does not.
So it's kind of annoying.
ELLIE: Well, you're going to
be limited by your download
bandwidth probably
anyway, right?
MALE SPEAKER: It doesn't
really matter.
For example, me, I have 100
megabits per second.
So nothing's going
to slow it down.
You guys are going to give us
one gigabit sometime soon.
RICHARD: If you're in Kansas.
ELLIE: Only in Kansas.
RICHARD: Three clicks.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, eventually
we'll reach worldwide, I hope.
RICHARD: All right.
Well, I'd like to thank the
GPDC, Google Play Developer
Console Preview team
for joining us from
wherever they are at.
I don't know where that is, in
a magic office somewhere.
And thank you for
your questions.
We'll see you Wednesday, 2:00
PM UK time, 3:00 PM CET for
our office hours.
NICK: Join me and Roman
Nurik tomorrow for
Android Design in Action.
We'll be talking about what
your Android design needs.
RICHARD: Please do.
Android design is very important
to all of us.
Thank you very much.
NICK: Thanks and bye.